what do you say what do you see what
have you noticed any takers are there
patents all square numbers yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna draw a square okay all
square numbers have an odd number of
yeah might be steady they all have an
odd number of factors everything else
including the primes have an even number
of factors okay that's kind of weird
what would that be why is it that the
squares only have an odd number of
factors oh maybe I should ask it the
other way
why do all those other numbers why I
always seem to end up with an even
number of factors yeah you're very good
what does it mean to be a factor the
opposite of a factor is a product it's
product a product is when you take two
factors two factors that you multiply
them together and you always need two
parts to it right so for example can't
look at 24 24 so much for ps1 right
these numbers here I'm not just six
random numbers it's actually sorry ain't
rainbows it's not a brand of numbers
it's four pairs do you see it's for
pants look in fact I can climb down and
you can see it right okay
124 two and twelve three and eight four
and six they are paired up right so it's
not just a coincidence that I have eight
I have two lots of four that's really
what's going on so that should answer
for us why the squares have odd numbers
a fact why is that
because they sweat right there will
always be one factor in the list namely
the square root this guy and where I'm
on this guy where is he this guy and
this guy that pairs up with itself
because he's like forget you guys right
plant my turn okay he doesn't need to
pair with it in fact with another factor
because he's his own pair right now hold
on a second
you said the squares have up odd numbers
of factors that's true but what if the
squares is different
did you notice that they've all got
three factors except for one why does
six days
why does 16 not have three factors yeah
ah when you have the square roots of
these guys right this is the square root
of two this is the square root of three
I'm gonna skip that guy for a second
what's this the square root of five two
three five we already know that three
three and five are important don't we
where are they appointed with enterprise
one two three and of course this guy is
the square of a square right
or more specifically there's a square of
a composite not mark okay
that's what's useful to us because if
you have a look what's the next time
we're going to be the next square I mean
it's gonna be 36 let's just skip a few
because 36 is interesting let's go to
Phase six what are the factors let's
just do a wall now together
now just like without other numbers we
noticed that the factors are in pairs
except for the square root right so you
go there there there there and then you
get to the middle
how many factors have we counted up
how is that that's nine nine factors
right definitely more than three even
more than five or seven right we skip
straight to nine and that was just our
next square right so what is it that six
has more factors and 16 has more factors
because they're not squares of primes
like these other guys up five and three
a two okay now can you see right all
we've been doing just looking at very
simple simple things but this gives us a
rabbit hole to go down okay this is like
whom there's something going on here
it's a little bit like you're a hunter
and you're looking for prey okay and
this like a little bit a little area
over here just like there's something
sort of rustling in there I'm gonna go
chase down this lead okay I want to push
like this you've taught me a lot about
square numbers yeah I'm gonna let you
think about that that's a great question
that is the kind of question which is
what it means to be deeply about a
simple thing okay I'm going to now ask
you to I'm gonna use your time I'm gonna
pose this question to you now all right
we've noticed something about the UM
squares and how many factors they are
but we haven't noticed anything about
the rest of the numbers okay you told me
they're even but why is it sometimes I
get four and sometimes I get six or
eight why do I get four sometimes what
is it that tells me that number of
factors that a numbers going to have
easier a way I could have predicted that
there would be nine factors or eight or
can I predict a number that might have
say twelve factors is this something in
here that can tell me that have a play
I'm giving you a lot of clues see what
you can work out